this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is funded by our supporters
on patreon not only do they make it
possible for us to make this show they
also get a bunch of extra content for
five dollars a month you get completely
ad-free versions of all podcasts and for
ten dollars a month you get extra
content which for idiots and abroad
includes an episode of the show that we
decided not to publish publicly and the
audio from the live show as soon as we
get it patreon is intended to be
entirely not-for-profit the whole thing
is just about making more and better
content so if you like the show and you
want to support even a dollar helps
patreon.com
hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of idiots and abroad this
episode is sponsored by Gundam Evolution
hell
can you believe it
much to Jacob's disappointment
you have an ad from them a little bit
further on in the video it's the best ad
I've ever made I love it
um and we're all very excited about it
John
where are you right now
I am in Kansas City but I won't be for
long what's going on there
as you can see
you've been wrong my room is empty it's
I brought back this this painting
digital painting it's not real art
um I'm moving back to L.A baby I'm so
excited I'm pretty excited if I'm
allowed to announce why but I am moving
back to LA baby and this podcast is over
this travel podcast really come a long
way well I find the pieces John do you
want to say where you're living I feel
like I alluded to it on a stream
uh I'm gonna be living with this old
Chrome
Alana is letting me live with her while
I look for a place and I might have
found a place I don't know you should
look at the uh did anyone watch the new
Netflix show roommates from hell oh not
yet have you watched it I'm aware watch
the first episode I'll ruin your [ __ ]
life about this sweet old [ __ ] oh no
uh-huh
I'm gonna start
would I be spoiling the episode if I
elaborate
no go for it well I'm gonna start like
getting people who need help and need
places to stay and then I murder them
all and bury them in my backyard
ah your backyard is AstroTurf you don't
know that it's real gross
yeah it would be really difficult you
have to clean the dog [ __ ] out of it
that might be easier because you just
pull it back like a carpet yeah I put
the dead bodies under the astero that's
why she went wrong
that's why she went wrong
oh dang that sounds good no she went
wrong killing people who had relatives
yeah because she was she was trying to
only find people who were like
almost like homeless and and stuff like
that
and she was claiming all of their um
like Social Security
and she was making so much money
the the title of the show makes it sound
like it's just gonna be it's gonna be
all drama but no there's a it's more
murdership
I mean it is dramatic but it's not like
drama drama it's not like drama is that
that's with that Network the House of
Usher no Netflix or um
putting up a documentary on April 6th or
7th about Jimmy Savile do you know Jimmy
Savoy is because you're sure yes I think
I do it was like yeah yeah knighted by
the queen yeah um his whole thing I mean
I even I wrote to him as a kid uh to get
touched up but
um but he's not interested in
um brown kids but but I know his whole
thing when you when you're a kid is you
write to him Jim will fix it
um and like you'd say you know hey Mr
Savile I wanna my letter was
um that I I'd like to ride in the
Batmobile Michael Keaton's one
um and I would have sucked his dick for
it
yeah I didn't know that that was I
didn't know that was the exchange of
goods I didn't know I just thought he he
just he just ask and he fixed it but
that was his whole thing was he was
super generous oh Shuckle your dick
I speak as an American child
I realized they're just doing a Waterboy
impression yeah
um but yeah so then and then like he
died he like he got away with it
died and then everyone came forward and
it was the first real massive me too it
was way before Weinstein way before that
and it was sexual abuse pedophilia
sexual abuse this is so Netflix this but
you should everyone should watch it
because it's like a cultural
John what did you just do
uh don't worry about it I'm moving my
father is here and some chunk collectors
came don't worry about it okay I could
tell you Dad we said hi
Maybe
maybe I'll bring him over
show us where it is I find it
exceptionally funny when Rahul
specifically [ __ ] up his phrasing of
something I don't know why I think it's
because he's so odd that when he says
making a guest of an appearance it
entertains me greatly I find that like
there's always a specific thing with
everybody I know that makes me laugh
like super hard whenever they do it yeah
with you Jacob it's anytime you say
anything inappropriate I I oh get the
tickles yeah I know with um with Patrick
Brown because this happened recently
it's whenever he barks like a dog when
we're talking about like women in a
video yeah
I don't know it makes you laugh so hard
every time this is a good bit
uh will you saying I was gonna ask the
The Joker staircase song guide that's a
different Gary Garrett yeah uh English
pedophile
yeah I'm really starting out today's
travel podcast is [ __ ] just
absolutely banging topics heavy oh he's
talked about why did you say Jacob take
it back a sexy stuff no no no no no no
pedophiles Jacob you can't do that no
absolutely not oh I can't get this way
we don't have to have yes we do have the
contacts that Rahul Kohli um he's our uh
Shield
yeah before this gets clipped and we all
later today we have a text conversation
where we go we I don't know if we should
start with that I was sexually abused as
a child so I'm allowed to make fun of it
yeah I'm owning my pain yeah
rap3 no I wasn't
[Laughter]
I feel
as a Survivor as a Survivor I've been a
white man I'm I'm giving you a pass to
to make light if it makes me feel better
well thank you I appreciate it also I
like that really again we had to
literally scrub the last episode we
decided not to publish it uh we recorded
a whole episode that we decided not to
publish mostly because of tech but also
because of some things and uh I'm gonna
put it up on patreon though what were
the things well it wouldn't work if we
spoke about it now no we can we can we
can it was I I know that you told me off
because you went on and I went on that I
went on a massive rant about how much I
hate something but to be clear oh yeah
yeah I didn't tell you off I just said
was very surprised that you were
comfortable doing that
I was talking about a job yeah I mean
quite negatively and I was like not my
current one everywhere
okay going off on that
uh in any case we have had some
Adventures since the last time that we
spoke because now we have to undo our
conversations about San Francisco John
and I went to San Francisco yep uh I
hosted some stuff at GDC it was a good
time
my father
it's my father
I think he's a very good model it's Mr
Smith he thinks you're Alana thinks
you're a very good one of my favorite
models
for I am
rocking that beanie right now yeah yes
you are rocking it he's rocking his
beanie it's like the burglars from Home
Alone
vibrations had positive vibration oh
cool guy representative all right thanks
Daddy I used to remind myself
kiss me on the lips no
dads are the best they are
good dad I too have a white father
hey same it's just Ravel out here all
right
Dad that said actually your dad is
pretty white are we showing pictures of
our dads well
I send my dad like yeah I said my dad
like it's internet he built a Gundam
keeping it themed he built rx78 because
I said it's a classic and um I'm like
I'm like the you know the reverse you
know the like the dad who doesn't show
up for the kid right but then just try
to send some gifts from afar because
they're do I do that to my parents so I
don't spend time with them I'll just
they'll just open up and it's a Lego
bonsai tree and they're like okay
um my dad supports Arsenal Football Club
but I send
for no reason I said a Liverpool Nike
top
um
why not and he looks so angry having to
wear it
that's an amazing fun she's doing that I
like him
no context that was it
for a word from our sponsor a very
exciting sponsor Jacob may be the Gundam
Meister Master but everyone at idiots
and abroad loves Gundam and when we
heard about this game we were super
stoked it turns out they're stoked as
well that's right we're talking about
Gundam Evolution on the podcast Gundam
evolution is a free to play 6v6 shooter
video game from Bandai Namco Online
Evolution pilot units from across the
Gundam Multiverse an intense 6v6
objective-based combat I'm talking
Universal Century I'm talking Calamity
War you name it oh and I could and the
game has high speed combat just like
real gun you know like when that song
kicks in in the anime that's like
Gundam Evolution the world of Gundam
evolution is always evolving oh you've
Evolution nice with a continuous flow of
new maps units customization items and
game modes to explore
[Music]
personalize your Gundam experience like
never before with unit weapon skins
stamps emotes and all that good stuff
make this little guy proud do it for
omro do it for Char do it for umikazuki
utilizing a unique boost system you just
boost your way right into the high speed
combat which everybody loves you're
gonna have a great time I can't wait not
every Gundam is the same we got unit
exclusive skills y'all so the xia is
going to be like the tongies is gonna be
like I'm big in other ones proper timing
and coordination is the key to Victory
the idiots in a broad crew is gonna play
it together we've been talking about
this in the group chat for literally
months maybe turn the tides of battle
with unit specific G Maneuvers all that
good stuff so apparently you're more
likely to win if you cooperate with your
teammates and you know balance out your
different skill loadouts and you kind of
like compliment each other but as you
all know I hate Jacob and I did any of
that I'm getting Rogue so make sure you
register to play right now we are very
excited about the PC closed Network test
and have all already registered so make
sure you join us by clicking the link in
the description we are going to be
playing so maybe you'll even get to play
against us back to the podcast
um but we went to San Francisco
we did
it
is still a beautiful city every time
that I ever go there I feel a little bit
annoyed about how walkable it is it's a
city that is designed basically for like
adults to just be able to go to a bar
and go to a coffee shop and then sit in
the park It's [ __ ] amazing like it's
so
I lived there for a while and it's so
nice to be able to do that also every
friend I had lived a 15-minute walk from
me so we'd like text each other and be
like want to see a movie in 30 minutes
and then you just walk there incredible
um sounds about white
uh there were a lot of people of color
in that friend group thank you
several
uh uh and I always missed out about it
whenever I go back um flip side though
the
it's hard to phrase the homeless
situation has gotten worse which I don't
think there's anything wrong with
homeless people I don't like it when
people go I heard San Francisco's just
full of homeless like being homeless is
disgusting you should lend out your
spare rooms
um sorry I'm living there but the the
there are just a lot of people just
[ __ ] yell at you like there's like a
massive mental health I love you on IGN
yeah and you're like get a job you're
back
there was also
yeah I mean for me my apartment and we
shouldn't dwell on it because it's sad
it's not that fault um but my apartment
uh my hotel was across the street from
like a center where they were giving
stuff out because it got crazy bad
during cover time and I didn't realize
everyone was homeless I was out there at
night
walking in the grocery store and then
they were hipsters yeah there were all
these hipsters they're all these like
older people there are all these nerds
there were all the it was just like oh I
guess this is just like a fun place to
hang out at the party Zone yeah yeah and
then I realized oh sh like all of these
people lost their jobs during covet and
they're just like
they're on the streets it's not San
Francisco's so expensive right like I
was I was working at IGN I was the host
of The Daily fix and I was producing a
bunch of that Flagship podcast
and I couldn't afford a pair of shoes
and then you go around that City and
you're like
where are all the rich people and then
you walk into a neighborhood and you
realize how different it [ __ ] is like
the rich neighborhoods you're like
oh they have like luxury ice cream
stores and there's just all these rich
people in like Lululemon yoga pants with
the tiny dogs and you're like cool okay
great I lived in the tenderloin uh when
I lived there which is like the least
safe part of the city because it was all
I could afford
um actually technically I was in the
tender knob because it was Knob Hill
Meats tenderloin so they called it
tender knob which is great
uh and what do you think about that Raul
attend a knob about tender tender knob
uh I think I was how old was I blinking
it back about six when I had my first
tendon on
uh
that's like one wrong Street
it would be like unsafe
um yeah so it you know it's got It's got
some shady Parts but the rich people in
that City really do be thriving they're
just so far above everyone else the the
poverty line there is or you're
considered low income there if you're
earning under 130 000 a year oh my God
yeah that's when I would have been I
would have been low income last year I
just realized I didn't work because
everything got put back so low income
but you don't hear me [ __ ] crying
about it
so we went to San Francisco it's
beautiful love it there recommend
visiting it's a nice city you can walk
the whole thing John how was your
experience what'd you get up to
all right my highlights
I had an Italian sandwich
not an Italian which is one of Jacob's
favorite types of sandwiches but there's
this place called Molinari wait what's
it's like the Jacob sandwich
Jacob likes an Italian an Italian is
like a type of sandwich with mustard
green cheese and stuff on it yeah yeah
you go to like Subway or is it or
anything
small mommies and uh pepperoni salami
Cola Nam provolone tomato onion okay I
didn't even know that was not put
capicola on it
these fast food places but uh yeah so
I got a nice sandwich with some
mozzarella some turkeys some hot peppers
some dope ass bread where'd you get it
from
molinaries oh you said that I also
bought a bunch of uh cured sausages
which I was going to give to you guys
and then I ended up gifting them to
Bones so
that's right how are you going to gift
us sausages
when I saw you guys you were gonna bring
them the whole way
yeah they're air cured they will live
forever thanks for that that popped up
on the screen recording
so I guess we'll just jump to that
so we did a live show
in Los Angeles that also I want to keep
telling my story oh you're more about
John we'll jump back I'm just I'm doing
my best no no no no it's fine
that one didn't show up
because I've clicked on it
I'm gonna send John a secret message let
me oh you sent it just to me the others
can't see it oh I see okay
um the whole world can so we'll get back
to you [ __ ] your meats or whatever
yeah
but we did do a live show in Los Angeles
huge thank you to everybody who came out
it was a super fun time Rahul gave away
some like a Warhammer kit we had people
come up and do like Impressions from
roll stop I'm being harassed in the chat
let me just roll this over so the
internet can see it
this is what's happening right now for
the audio listeners it says
Mark said we can post and then it says
how's your [ __ ] and then it says [ __ ]
please LOL nice
I'm being harassed I I'm gonna invest in
idiots in a broad HR just to deal with
Rahul guess who you're employing for HR
it's me absolutely I feel like you're
the perfect
democracy we should vote for it okay
raise your hand if you want Rahul to be
head of HR
[ __ ]
whoa John you have like all ass people
in your apartment moving stuff John just
sent it thank you well it's just trash
to talk about some of the most
embarrassing out of context stories
because they're right there right
they're right next to you that's true we
could make that fun dad's there too oh
um are we uh what are we talking about
we did a live show or the podcast in La
yeah we did thank you everyone who came
it was super fun I'm still waiting for
Rooster Teeth to give us the audio which
is going to go up on patreon and money
but they might have paid us out I don't
think they have so [ __ ] money yo yeah
Jacob
uh yeah it was on March 11 so I mean I'm
emailing them frequently about getting
the audio um but we're still just wait
waiting on it so it'll go up on patreon
when we have it thank you everyone who
came out it was super fun but we did we
did prepare something extra special
for one Jacob Fullerton Rahul would you
like to tell the story tell your tale
why don't we just
um Midway roll the clip okay roll it now
that's why I did it roll the clock roll
the clip should I cue it up yeah all
right I need audio on your laptop what
[ __ ] I [ __ ] hate you we need to
take you down and Peg I want everyone to
see this yeah
what's happening
[Applause]
hi Jacob it's Mark Hamill here you know
I was never particularly fond of you but
after working with Raul and hearing his
stories I'm convinced you're really a
truly awful person and I hate you
personal have a good day
Hamill
[Applause]
hi Jacob I don't even know what to say
camel hates you yes we have it on video
Mark Hamill says I hate you
I can't even like I can't mentally
function after that oh Jacob that's
crazy yeah oh my God I know I didn't
even like I didn't know I could have I
don't even know what to say
[Laughter]
for a whole how did that come about
oh so
um my boy on set mark I just hit him up
and I was like why don't you speak that
truth about Jacob and
um I was at the Games Workshop in
Glendale
looking at some sweet sweet
um Space Marines and ultramarines and
[ __ ]
and then the video came through
and it was that and I couldn't stop
laughing in the in the freaking in the
shop
um and then um I sent it John was
already at the event because
um Alana was late
and very late I was hosting the video
game accessibility Awards thank you yeah
that I created took you long enough yeah
but it was very difficult I'm sorry
what's more important
the disabled or Mark Hamill and Jacob
Fulton you can't even say his last name
right he said Fulton
to disabled yeah
is it yeah is it people with
disabilities you sons of [ __ ] no
Jerry's actually pretty out on that like
the every time I have to talk about
games with disabilities it's like people
take it offense to it in either
direction it's actually difficult to
find a consensus among the community
if you say disabled Gamers or Gamers
with disabilities people like strongly
which oh it's interesting in any case
that's like some people don't like
people like color some people of color
don't like being called colored or
people of color no you can't say color
s
so am I it's not my feelings
um
important it's not much
that's why I like being called a person
with obesity not a fat [ __ ]
you're not you're not obese
oh yeah do you not think it's messed up
I'm not morbidly yeah isn't that like is
morbidly obese PC
because they're using the word morbidly
no because they're gonna die I think
that's just a medical term
um yeah wrangling back Jacob yes before
we get off topic oh sorry
obese yeah I was in Games Workshop
because also at the time because we
always talk about Hobbies on here like
Gundam and you know painting and
airbrushing and all that [ __ ] I figured
you know also it was the fun house
[ __ ] podcast right not us we were
like the opening act even though losers
even though look at us we're [ __ ]
rock stars but whatever it's fine
everyone
I'm sure Eminem has opened for you know
smaller rappers but anyway yeah
um I wanted to weed out because I'm a
egomaniac who really I remember when I
asked the audience but who actually
knows this though in it and who's just
filling seats who's just waiting for the
main event so I bought some a starter
kit old a Space Marine starter kit and
what they had to do was their best
impression of us which had to so so we
got deep cuts of like wanna watch a
Gundam anime
you come
um and then we gave it uh as a price uh
someone did an impression of us and they
won uh Space Marines and also
John because Alana was late uh put got
the video up on the laptop I was late
too but she was hosting the
accessibility
no I was chilling yeah I think while I
was hosting the accessibility Awards you
were posting pictures of the Gundam
store you were at
injection
s
great work this is amazing Raul's
shopping
no what I was doing is I stayed there
longer I kept taking off my mask because
it was before the mass mandate whatever
stop just to see if anyone in Games
Workshop recognized me
that's a good that's a much better
reason too John and I were like Jacob
and I are like sitting there going test
test Mike test one two because the there
was a call for the mic test and it was
just me and Jacob but we had a good time
it was fun uh and also the guy who the
audio engineer
didn't tell us when it was over so
because we just had to talk yeah so he's
like just just talk just talk and then
so we were talking we talked for like 10
minutes and I realized that dude it just
left and I was like is the mic check
over and the guy didn't even and we're
like okay we're done and we just got it
um but Jacob
yes what was your reaction to seeing
Mark Hamill cussed you out like that as
you deserve
um I had a very uh public freak out it
was um I was I definitely didn't know it
was it was gonna happen
I am very easy to to trick that is true
and conceal things from it seems very
easy to see wait what did we trick him
oh yeah for the birthday party for the
birthday yeah
at all the whole time we put we put way
too much thought into it and he didn't
question a [ __ ] things nope in
hindsight I was all it was all like
really weird
Gundams at him John took him to Little
Tokyo yeah my most vulnerable but I was
like
flabbergasted I never I don't think I
ever would have like known what reaction
I was gonna have I mean I'm sure if it
was just like a normal situation I would
have kept my cool but this was like just
thrust upon me in front of a live
audience on a really big screen so it
was like I just I just chose every time
the first line is just hey Jacob it's
Mark Hamill like and I'm like oh let's
take him that was like it was like a my
like heart and he's watched he's watched
that video so he knows who you are you
know okay so he's actually seen the yeah
oh yeah yeah you sit there and show him
sundered that's you do to everyone and
then you're just looking at him yeah at
his reaction yeah
oh
mum's watched it um I showed it to a
cast member on blind Manor
and everyone I've ever shown it to
cracks up and that's good it's a great
video it's super funny and no one takes
anything seriously and I showed it to a
cast member and they were like
I don't know if you should be joking
about that kind of stuff and the root
that the energy and the wind in my sail
just like so I've stopped showing it
just because someone was like
uh you're probably not wrong you
probably shouldn't just they're probably
not child porn out yeah still don't know
the context of that I for a long time
was like I could probably look up the
file again
but I don't know I was eating Cheetos
loudly yeah and I think I hear something
I don't know what I heard but I that's
why I I thought I misheard something oh
in the moment
because I'm eating Cheetos and I think I
just hear child porn
I can't remember
um I still think there's there's a few
moments in there in that standard video
that are like some of the tightest
comedic live stream cut together moments
from like I gotta go put the legs back
on my sex doll sex dolls such a witty
joke
oh my God but just before that it's like
Post Old after that is the puss pics
yeah and you're like I've never sent the
whole thing it goes into John doing the
story as well it goes immediately until
how big is a [ __ ] Banger there you go
and meets a girl Dan edited them she did
yeah Dan actually deserves the credit
more than yes Gotham
[Music]
being used the font yeah uh related
anybody who has not watched that video
because I know some of the people who
watch this podcast aren't from fun house
I'll leave a link it's it's basically
like the four of us happened to come
together to make something and it was
like my favorite Funhouse video ever I I
I remember it really clearly because I
was my dad was visiting me
and I went to LAX and dropped him off
and then I stopped by the office because
it was super close right and I was
chilling and Bruce was supposed to do
sundered with you three that's what was
scary probably wasn't even me because I
was like not in videos at the time are
you sure not a lot it was very yeah you
went far between that I would be in the
video maybe it was Peak I think it was
because Matt had set it up and and it
was great he's the one who's like y'all
should play this game I love this this
game would be such a good video yeah we
also did a witness gameplay with Matt
one time that I don't think Eva got
published because he was like the
witness is great I was like I agree
no no this is the best gameplay game
though my friend but I wasn't I wasn't
meant to be on anything
and then their meeting went over and
over and and I said to Bruce a common
what happened but it ended up being like
I was like well I'll sit in I don't mind
if you've got to do [ __ ] I'll do one and
then all four of us find ourselves in
that room
and then that happens and who knew
because we were all friendly yeah but I
think that was the Genesis of us
realizing like oh we're all in the same
wavelength
very much so yeah because I didn't like
I'm excited I hung out with John plenty
but I don't think I was like social with
like Alana and Rahul yet yeah Bruce
Bruce and them kept us kept us editors
wrangled we were never able to meet the
guests I went out I know I had
I'd say like with John
we went out for a few drinks like a few
times I'd come back from filming a
zombie we'd come out right and we'd go
up in like Culver and that's that's as
far as rent and me and Jacob teetered
and flirted
very briefly when we watched solo yeah
quiz show yeah so I knew like I like so
I always liked you both but never you're
right like yeah whenever I came into the
office it was like
you know I would do on camera stuff and
Bruce would Shuffle you into the
producer's room and like pull the blinds
pointed that editing room yeah and then
I'd like and then I would I would so
Bruce I'd chill with James and Elise in
the office or I'd go to the bathroom
with Adam
uh-huh
and you'd leave alone
I was sending an email
what are you doing reading an email
during our practice it's work it's work
related oh my God what is even work
what's work wow
but yeah it's a great video yeah it is a
great video yeah I've never heard the
origin story I didn't know yeah and they
almost weren't gonna just get called
into a room I make the funny funny and
then I go back to work did you because
she has my story did you hear that from
Milano they almost aren't gonna publish
it is
a bunch of weirdos yeah because because
it wasn't because it wasn't cool gang I
remember a thing because like I was I'll
be I was asked to be and I'm like they
must have nobody oh Jacob yourself well
I mean that camera that wasn't I mean
that was the time back in the day that
like producer would encourages that when
they were gone traveling filming or
anything Bruce would be like yeah you
guys should shoot shoot stuff and then
we'd shoot it and it would never get
edited or or it would just be like a
rooster teeth exclusive yeah yeah yeah I
would go on first or whatever yeah yeah
because the two of you are so good like
that's what happened to our Star Wars
quiz it went on First and never it never
never served it's there's there's no way
to find anything well actually sorry
I love Rooster Teeth I love roosteep.com
Rooster Teeth for uh having us I'm gonna
pass this one up to burn you 100 but
think about that yeah think about that
yeah just think about it think about it
yeah no disrespect to anyone because
it's all love and and like that's so
British no disrespect to anyone because
it's all love followed by a very fat
butt but yeah and then this is that's
what we're doing I don't know [ __ ]
wind up no it just shows you sometimes
like you never know it's just like
movies it's like TV shows you never you
never know right like that video could
have just landed on the on the scrap
Heap because who cared no when we came
out of that room I feel like I was like
that I thought to have it published I
was like that video is really good
please edit it well yeah well
we the problem with it was there was no
footage and we didn't even yeah the
gameplay broke that's right and then not
long afterwards I was approached by
Bruce and Dan
and Bruce was like hey
this one's real spicy of you like this
is the worst behaved you've ever been on
camera like you're making jokes about
this and that
and he was like do you want me to Nix
this and I was like I'm good and then I
went out for a cigarette and it was when
Dan used to smoke Dan comes up to me and
goes
uh are you cool with that video
and I was like yeah I don't like we're
making fun of like I never go yeah
everyone [ __ ] I mean it's a comedy
channel like where what you're
effectively doing in a fun house video
is making the same kind of content that
a stand-up comedian is making just
nowhere near as good but
let's really pull it together but it is
a comedy channel like it should be taken
as we are trying to say things to make
people up and you're not you guys did
try to convince me that my mother is a
pedophile that's true that did happen in
that video also
which is like a very good example is
like that's the thing I didn't even
necessarily believe but it's sometimes
just more entertaining to take a hard
stance yeah yeah and John you spoke
about your dad in that you know knowing
that you were as well oh yeah I did talk
about my daddy and oatmeal realizing or
him being aware that I was masturbating
in my bedroom yeah I don't even remember
what I talked about oh it was just
Jacob's shampoo
he's not making eye contact what else
can we get John to say oh there he is
yeah John tell us about the first time
that you masturbated in great detail
and I already did damn it tell us
another time that you
paid for uh sex
okay so
uh
so I'm selling my apartment or I'm
moving away selling your apartment okay
yeah I'm moving away
and so my landlords are like hey could
you show people the apartment
um oh and I was like yeah totally you're
tearing them through I thought the thing
through so they're like okay there's
gonna be a guy here Thursday morning at
10 A.M so I go down
I opened the door
and the guy goes
John
and I was like yeah
um and if I wasn't moving out that would
have been a nightmare like a nightmare
yeah
um but luckily I was moving out and he
and he's a super cool dude we actually
have been dming on Instagram
um he keeps trying to hang out with me
wait someone dm'd me asking me for a
favor a favor is he in film School
I was just at John's Apartment uh can
you help me I'm in film school why did
you think it's the same guy
no because someone messaged me saying um
hey
um my dissertation or so something's due
and I'm doing a thing on on diversity
can I have 30 minutes of your time to
talk about diversity and you assume that
they went to John about that too yeah
John and John can John uh ask John Smith
about me he can vouch for me and tell
you I'm not a creep oh what that's a
weird thing to follow it up with I
wouldn't take that vouch either if
someone was like John can confirm I'm
not a creep I'd be like I know that's
what that's what the D.A said you're
gonna need to someone else about that uh
yeah I mean I don't know who that could
have been I don't probably a creep I'm
gonna talk about diversity I don't do
any of those I get asked about uh
University stuff all the time and I
don't do any of them because twice in a
row I was doing all of them anytime
anybody needed like thesis help or an
interview from somebody who worked in
the games industry I would do all of it
twice in a row people lied and said that
it was for University and then actually
just published it on their YouTube
channel or on their shitty gaming blog
so now all the students are cut off
which sucks but
with really quick lady headlines and
then they tried to put it all over
Reddit and like it was just like [ __ ]
that man so now you said so many
controversial things too yeah especially
in my University student chats
where you're at your most crass I'm
trying to be informative for the
education system I really go all out
yeah I just I just find it funny that
like
very rarely are you asked like
hey can we talk to you about being an
actor like Alana you have this too right
where it's like interview questions they
want to talk to us yeah they want to
talk talk about being a victim yeah can
you tell us about pressure harassment I
say no I have a blanket no to harassment
which my manager is always just like
replies to very swiftly then I'm like
the minute that you ask me about working
in video games
if you ask me about being a woman and
being harassed I sometimes now for
interviews say the rule is don't ask me
about harassment you can interview me
but there will be no questions about
what's it like but then and the [ __ ]
up thing is is that if you keep if you
say yes and you're like people have the
best intentions right like we'd like to
share a spotlight on it and we want to
hear can I just get criticized for
talking about but then you get
criticized because it sounds like all
you talk about is is
asking me to um
speak to a professor at Harvard I think
um about representation in in cinema
um
yeah and I know that's a pretty big
school here in the United States is it
no yeah is it like your Hogwarts exactly
essentially like what are the other
schools I don't remember Yale a bunch of
rich people to make each other
yeah
what's the one in the office he keeps
talking about is Yale there's that um
thingy's character Andy keeps saying
he's from Cornell Cornell oh yeah
everyone else real is real yeah it is I
actually I don't remember where I was I
think I was maybe it was uh in the
airport waiting but someone was like I
went to Cornell and so they literally
they like that they were setting it up
that was the validation for what they
were talking about and I know they
actually did that oh my God it's real
life that is a weird part of the
American system is like this like the
cultish college thing I went to the
Queensland University of Technology
nobody would have it with Oxford and
Cambridge like if you or E2 yeah what's
eaten
who the [ __ ] has a what do you call a
college Eaton sorry Eaton do you know
where Eaton is Eaton's where James Bond
went
Jameson isn't real Rahul wow
and the royal family send their boys
their the prime ministers went to
Community College
yeah
he went to Eaton Eaton yeah eaten
Barbies I just got a pop-up ad that's
scary there's nothing open dude if you
install any Korean apps on your computer
they're just all chill with just Papa
pads like really I felt like it was like
1998 again yeah I installed uh uh cacao
talk
um you don't have a means to like have
ads turn off
no there's no strange they just have
pop-up ads and it was like Korean gaming
peripherals are they cool though
I don't want to be showing ads I worked
in commercial production for years and I
hated it I've never watching that again
no
just so you guys except for the one in
this video thank you to gundam Evolution
for the sponsoring yes thank you
Evolution
always use an ad blocker you're muted
ruffle you touch the top of your
microphone probably
no I'm not yeah there you go
how did you know that to me
yeah because it says mute I didn't think
I touched it I think you did oh it does
say that happened no it was just that
yeah how cool was it that you know
sundered was never gonna make it blah
blah blah blah blah and then you know a
year later [ __ ] begging me to
make sure I show up to do the podcast
[Applause]
that wasn't about the rest you mean now
dad he's looking at me
congrats you did it
um yeah and we got you know we got more
camel so that's very cool oh yeah that
was very flabbergasted yes Jacob like do
you think you'll ever recover have you
peaked is it done for you now can you
yeah I want I watch it every couple days
so
probably not it's just alarm clock now
yeah now we gotta get uh Jacob to meet
the guy who voices Amaro
oh but what would everybody's equivalent
be I think if you did that for me and it
was Donald Glover I actually I have a
panic attack I actually tried once for
you for Tessa Tessa Thompson I mean I
have a big crush on Tessa Thompson but
it's not she's not quite Donald Trump
why
I'd freak out about if you've got
Childish Gambino to say something I I
think I'd throw up
I know you guys are trying to figure out
who would be for me uh just you know
it's no one I'd give you a K-pop
no
first off first off that's not possible
um I don't ever want to I I have no
desire to meet anyone I'm the same
if I if I appreciate someone's work and
stuff it's just like I appreciate you we
might have said this I do not have any
need to meet you I will not get 100
exception awkward I don't I think we may
have said this on the the removed
episode but yeah um when Andy Samba came
to the IGN office he was one of my first
ever crushes I left I just left I saw
him and I was like no I just left the
building because I didn't want to be
around him I also if I see celebrities
don't want to talk to them
I'm good I don't need any of it yeah any
same person yeah
Gillian Jacobs and an ArcLight you're
just gonna sneak that in there he
doesn't remember that he he denies it
what happened
it snuck a little comment it didn't
nobody heard it
what do you say don't worry about it
it's fine you have to watch it um sorry
John what did you say
well I was saying my dad cornered a
celebrity at an arc light one time and
he refuses to acknowledge it but also
which celebrity I just I just don't I
just don't really I'm not I'm not into
the whole celebrity thing or not not
into it I just don't it doesn't affect
me like one time I was sitting at my
desk working away when I worked at this
place called electus who was a reality
TV show and someone behind me goes
excuse me and I turn around and it's Ed
Helms and he goes hey I'm looking for
this office
from it's Andy from The Office
um oh no I was thinking of someone else
I was thinking of Ed Harris
who just died
and he appeared behind you and it was oh
my God a ghost yeah he's like hey I'm
looking for this office and I was just
like I'll show you
and then I sat down and I just kept
working I'm I'm the same it does there's
no part of my brain that cares about
time I didn't text anybody I don't care
boy
I think well firstly I'm a fanboy
because a lot of them are my peers so
like they're people that influenced me
to do the job that I'm doing so there's
a work appreciation equal like peers are
equal
but
I'll tell you this I like there are a
few people
there are a few people that I would make
exceptions for like
um
I mean like if you guys played me a
video and Clint Eastwood no you're a
fanboy all the time Rahul you're a
little Fanboy I am a little Fanboy but
like
within reasons
I don't freak over like Mark anymore
like on the first day whenever he's on
set I was like who cares about Mark
Hamill now yeah yeah I mean
but but like on the after after the
initial meeting it became like an actor
on set an older actor who I would make
sure was okay and like are you doing
you're right and and whatever but you
can't be taking your meds today because
you're friends now your exact feeling
yeah because you but but like and I've
seen like celebrities out and like met
like a-listers sometimes and it's and it
is a bit like holy [ __ ] wow and then
it's you know whatever but
[ __ ] off Alana because
what would you do if you got into an
elevator and Jurgen klopp or Mo Salah or
someone was in there who or Virgil Van
Dyke they're just different oh
you don't want to know what happened
it's not fanboying that is Fanboy that's
100 you don't want to know what happens
if I'm in the room with Virgil Van Dyke
oh hold on nothing came up for Virgin
Cora rakala who who's the first person
you said Virgil Van Dyke he's my number
one Crush right now
b-i-r-g-i you know that's not the first
version you said multiple people oh I
said Jurgen klopp Masala yeah yeah I
would like but that's that's different
to me too what about Andy Robinson what
about Jordan Henderson any of the
starting 11. you would no you wouldn't
that's our captain who are all this
Annie though go for it
um sounds like you're naming Gundams
well no so the reason that I apparently
have disheveled hair and no makeup on
and whatever is that I woke up
part for now before this podcast because
uh Rahul and I obviously separately were
both awake watching a Liverpool game uh
which started at 4 30 A.M so we just
stayed up for it
uh big one though because we are what
happened in the city game role
oh they won two yeah tight that's sick
uh right next week
we were on the top for a few hours we
went to bed yeah we went to bed top of
the league which never happens and we
woke up back to back to seconds I do
want to be clear Alana you don't
actually look much better than you
normally do just see him
[Laughter]
I don't wear a lot of makeup but I don't
do a lot to my hair so thank you the
standard is pretty low anyway it wasn't
a compliment no I know I'm sleepy
because I stayed up playing Elder ring
too late again that is much cooler it's
much cooler oh Jacob that's it I'm up
too I know John watched me finish the
game I did
I'm just drawing it again did remote
things
I don't know if it's actually been
implemented yet but they added or
advertised at least a feature for the
PS5 that's picture in picture so you can
watch somebody play like on the screen
while you're playing and I [ __ ] love
that that you could watch someone play
one of your friends play Elven ring
while you're playing Elden ring that's
cool ring in your Eldon ring so you can
Elden ring while your Eldon ring there's
this one day uh when it was during the
pandemic when there was a very dramatic
thing that happened with fun house I'm
not gonna say what
um but yeah but then like a day or two
after because we were all feeling weird
um we all just hopped on Discord and it
was right after Hades came out and we
and it was like me Omar I always been
there once
yeah and a bunch of other people were
coming in and out but we were just all
casting our own screens
and just playing Hades and just hanging
out so we weren't doing multiplayer we
were all just playing video games and
hanging showing each other and like yeah
and I remember that day and it's like
why don't we do that every time playing
video games why don't I just hit someone
up and why did it yeah why did it have
to take this for us to hang out yeah
all the time I love just like playing
separate games and just being able to
talk to each other yeah totally yeah oh
yeah Jacob yeah I was I put on Eldon
ring yesterday are you okay
Rahul sounds like trash because
of I don't know how much I can say
it's work related if you recorded it on
his phone things happened to his vocals
oh I know his participation to his whole
thing I thought it was just the phone I
mean it is but like he he was obviously
Mark Hamill punched him in the throat oh
that's so cool can you do that to me
next time the next live show we're gonna
pay my camera punch you in the throat
yeah
um no it was work like a big heavy day
yeah takes its tolls that's why the ads
like well the Gundam Evolution six
player free to play looter shooter then
basically yes yes
I was I was basically this week was
um my kind of
busy busy busy week at work
um basically me on set in every scene
and um
and by the time
I wrapped and we'd done like at one
point was like we did a eight was I was
it it was like 17 hours or something oh
it's been on set so it was a real it was
a real slog it was physical and you
still do something else and yeah I blew
my throat out but and then Alana was
like the day I did the 17 hours long I
was like we need the ad read and so I
came home she was like if you can do it
it's real short if you just do it on
your phone I came in and I fell asleep
up right there fully dressed for eight
hours like that
right and I I had a like a burger
because that the only thing was open was
like a [ __ ] McDonald's or something
so I hadn't eaten I woke up still had
makeup on
horse I climbed under the duvet with my
boy phone memos and I went
you want to be cooperative with Clinton
and strengthen the abilities it's the
first thing I did I said it's Alana
appreciate you doing it anyway thank you
and I was like I felt like I'd been hit
by a car because it was a lot of stunts
and lots of crazy stuff going on and
your body just like and especially when
you when you're really over exerting
yourself vocally as well you're I have
this sometimes when you do vo like gears
these muscles here huh are like so
painful the next day because of God
because the amount of head you've been
given
it's Hollywood baby yeah seriously why
do you think my Flanigan loves me so
much
um but but but yeah and then um
so I'm like I could barely move
everything hurts and I put on Elder and
Craig because I was like okay it's my
day off I'm gonna play some video gonna
relax with some nice chill Elden Rings
five seconds five seconds in I'm I
realized I stopped before some boss
battle and it's that chick that does
magic also the one with all the students
that bite your toes it starts with the
students the second part of Ronaldo she
killed she one hit me on the second part
immediately and it was over to shoot you
with a big laser yeah because because of
the Frailty of my body and mind and
voice it's the only time I never
immediately started a boss fight again I
just went no no
I had no fight in me I was just like no
yeah
you were going to ask Jacob a question
yeah about igb uh is it is it oh no not
how to beat her is she old no like that
just have to watch over that move when
you come in it was that one freaking
thing that happened to catch me you
gotta be quick yeah because that that
fight isn't very difficult sometimes
she'll you may lay him aggressive yeah
you can beat the [ __ ] out of her that
fight gets harder with times yeah the
faster you can how so drain her health
bar
because she keeps summoning yeah the
second phase she summons like John you
were telling me that like your summons
weren't so bad when you fought her
but like yeah Jacob she kept summoning a
dragon the first time I fought her I
almost got her down well this okay it
was the second time hit you with that
laser
is what radonna is optional you don't
have to fight him because you don't even
have to go to Caleb right I think he
only have to kill a couple of like the
big main bosses yeah you don't have to
kill him
you know what pissed me off though of
all the up to this point because I I've
been busy so I haven't been able to
really like have a good stint but I will
now but um that [ __ ] wolf dog before
her pissed me off so much like in Vulpix
or whatever he annoyed the [ __ ] out of
me yeah uh first first off but now it's
it's fine afterwards but yeah yeah I
just wanted to know I wanted to know if
I was in store for like a really because
I'm staying away from spoilers I'm not
looking at walk through so I was just
like I was wondering I was like am I in
for a rough ride because I'm still a bit
I don't feel as frail mentally and
emotionally as I was like yesterday yeah
like would I be okay so you just just
get in there and just attack because
yeah when I was fighting her
because she can summon all sorts of
random little things it might be like
dogs it might be this one night but she
kept so many like a huge dragon
that would fill up the whole screen and
then she would be behind the dragon
shooting magic at me and I couldn't see
her and I was like
why did she keep something through this
Dragon everybody was telling me this
this part like when they fought this
boss it was like wolves
I um also keeping things in check Jacob
Fulton Fulton
how do you feel about the new Gundam
announcement there's an anime you guys
John messaged in the group well right oh
wait I sent it
I don't know I think it was true I was
like oh a new anime yeah
um yeah that was the I I had known about
it coming out but they hadn't shown
anything it was just a title
um but yeah dude they know what like uh
timeline it is or any have they told us
anything it might just be on its own
somewhere like I am blooded orphans or
whatever yeah so there's multiple
timelines like it's not all within the
same universe and the same yeah there's
there's a big main one
and then there's just like side ones
that just are self-contained but it's
double O in the main one no
Alana laughed it's still good though add
rate because I could when when I was on
the phone to Alana when
you lot had just sent your ad reads and
she laughed when you said
um uh thingy's name from Iron blood uh
iron blood
dolphinsuki you remember Kazuki yeah I
was laughing so much at it again it was
it was great a Kazuki it's fun to edit
also speaking of Gundam I take questions
on patreon for for the podcast every
month uh there's one for Rahul which is
what's the most difficult Gundam you've
had to build so far
they're all different which one was the
hardest I I paint them yeah you make it
hard for yourself I make I make I make
high grades of pain in my balls
so the easiest one I've ever done is
barbatos in Vancouver during my covert
ice cream because I didn't have to paint
it and I just built it immediately and I
was like is this Gundam because my
Gundam experiences
[ __ ] the tiny arm is on a [ __ ]
toothpick with blue tack I'm airbrushing
it and doing panel lining I built this
giant blue boy
oh he's pretty Jacob have you ever done
GM sniper too no but I really want to I
haven't got my hands off GM sniper too
I can't I can't get back into Gundam
right now man I'm fully in the world of
Warhammer no John are you doing you're
painting
what are you doing your pain
you've not touched it have you
it's all packed well in the back of
yours I saw it all on that desk I did
the face wash
or the base coat
and then I where's he going he's gonna
show his ass again oh Bravo I heard that
one
nice oh and then I did a wash
and I feel like I [ __ ] it up and now
it's like what I realized is that
you have to be very precise
yeah
[Music]
I do not have steady hands why is that a
revelation
when you saw a brush and then thing this
big what made you think that it just is
a happy accident
I didn't think about it well because all
the videos I watch are [ __ ] masks
I will I will admit I will admit that
like say for celesto for instance
um
I usually watch him on a large screen
and then Seresto is so zoomed in and so
good it makes you think that the figures
are like six that's the other thing I
literally have to buy one of those
Jewelers mirrors and so I it has a light
on it and I bring it down because I was
like hunching over like this painting
and now my shoulders are hurting so much
that I bought one of those magnifying
glasses so I can sit upright and I can
paint without having to like
squint in that was an issue I had at
first with uh well I'm a two is I just
yesterday uh got my new glasses for my
updated prescription have you got them
on you have you got the money do you
want to put them on no I want to see him
glasses I just I have this issue with
glosses where no matter what they make
you look I look like a [ __ ] it doesn't
matter what kind they are they just make
me look like like mummy like MILF Pawn
it's unavoidable there is nothing I can
do about it well now we have to ignite I
have to go get them and that's a lot of
effort
the point was uh I put them on yesterday
and I was like oh my [ __ ] God
everything is so clear
and it had been years since I had
updated my prescription
uh can you guys stop harassing me in the
chat
please
stop it stop
thank you Jacob I'm gonna take that as
he said shush this Library
um
in my um profile picture that I used uh
it's
it came from an article because he's
someone who died yeah
that's the picture they had
so when I Google imaged it I didn't know
why are you gonna use that picture it's
it's the dad's selfie that's how my dad
takes selfies it's slightly below so
when I was on it's literally the top
picture and it says any man dies of
heart attack
day before flying home for good oh
so
I should change it oh you could you
could make fun of dead people I don't
like I didn't know but it was just it
was just it wasn't that I knew the story
it's just when you go I went Indian
selfie and that was like one of the top
ones and then I just used it thinking it
was a round I didn't know I was using a
mud as someone who died
um we got another question from patreon
the second one was Jacob how many
lightsabers do you own do you have a
favorite oh
um I have four I just got a new one
um and that one's my favorite what is it
because it's very loud it's is it in the
room it's your favorite because it's
loud oh it also has like uh I showed it
to Rahul last time when the we were
having connection issues and you guys
are in the hotel you couldn't hear us
now swinging it around didn't see that
yeah that was also when I was getting my
ass out you're taking your ass out of
here yeah um
Photoshop that I connected the two
pictures in in neither of you responded
oh that was that was good I laughed in
real life
oh I almost knocked over a giant stack
of Gundams
have you read all of Dark Tower
I've only read the first two but I
really enjoyed them oh that is nice
Stephen Stephen King dropped some
Humdinger of a tweet oh that completely
changes that could change potentially
the whole series oh that Roland is
actually gay or something it was Penny
who's Pennywise Pennywise and someone
might be the same entity in it like
Pennywise there's a lot of interest are
you talking about Dark Tower yeah yeah
yeah I mean I think there's the
Multiverse all of the The Dark Tower
addresses the Stephen King Multiverse
but all of his books
like are somehow connected the cosmos
yeah yeah and Dark Tower is the one that
addresses all that so supposedly
Pennywise he's the villain in Dark Tower
no well it's just like hate and darkness
and stuff right yeah there is there's
more specific Pennywise specifically is
like a villain in a lot of them
um
Pennywise in Dark Tower it's like uh
it's different characters it's but King
but King's saying it's the king is
saying that Robert and Pennywise are the
Siemens but isn't Pennywise in Dark
Tower
um no never
no maybe like eight years the alien yeah
it's the because he's an alien right
yeah
yeah he's like a doctor he's a Celestial
being or he landed before humans energy
right
I thought he he's an extraterrestrial
that landed before human evolution and
then slayed dormant and then came out to
feed I think he's he's like an ancient
being that has been around since the
beginning no let Jacob say that say that
again
I love that none of us know what it is
and we're just repeat like speculating
Jacob repeat that what about what alarms
um as as I as I said uh uh ancient
Celestial being she came from the
heavens and uh did he say it right
he's anxious he's an ancient again did I
[ __ ] say ancient yeah jump out the
window I've been working on it I've been
trying so hard to not say two hours a
day Jacob goes ancient are there any
other words that use ain't
I don't think so
ain't you got my money
look at the classic Rihanna song ain't
you got my money yeah
uh
anyways your girlfriend was hot like me
it's the creature has already awoken
several times to create destruction
cause panic and feed possesses people to
murder people whatever here's a fun
exercise
who would oh nice lightsaber my friend
is that the new one it is this is why
Mark [ __ ] hates you I sent you guys a
tick tock of some dude testing out
different like settings of a lightsaber
that was nuts wait what what that was a
good one right wow you sent some to some
some tick tocks yesterday to me that
made me laugh I do not even remember
anything that I sent I I just yeah you
just send them for it I was gonna say
I'm a curator fun exercise who would win
in a fight between it and the thing
uh and the thing like the alien
definitely it Kurt Russell the thing no
yeah because it it's strength
the Xenomorph
no way it's if between it and the thing
and Anakin no and also dead Anakin
I think I'm gonna think anything can
kill the thing Anakin probably I
actually just watched the thing with
director's might be right Anakin the
thing is incredible very intriguing John
Carpenter I think Alana was in The Ting
right Alana was in The Ting are you
trying to imply that I was in some smut
film no I was complimenting you I was
actually being nice for once normally we
make fun beef curtains I called you a
Ting thank you you said in the which for
some reason really upset John
I'm confused it is a road man yeah it's
a Ting someone someone's a ting
thank you it means a lot to me all right
fine she's a stupid [ __ ] she got messed
up vagina
[Applause]
oh look at her downcast eyes thanks
Jacob yeah
I was saying something very director's
car that I don't remember directions
oh the thing director's cut yeah I've
been getting so this is the death of
Cinema okay
okay DVDs
or some people south of Oregon dbds
um
they used to be packed full of special
features behind the scenes director's
commentaries all this stuff that as a
budding filmmaker a young boy who wants
to get into film nice song are you
talking about that guy that that wants
to interview me that you found out a
young boy yeah by the way I'm just a
young who wants to get it he's not a
creep I promise young boy I know John I
just feel like if you have to say by the
way I'm not a creep in your opening
message it's not a great design no yeah
all babies
not a creep not a nuns you are not a by
the way I've never murdered anyone
um yeah so what this the the direct
commentary special features yeah I
watched the I've I've been buying
Blu-rays and DVDs specifically to
consume all of that extra content
because I missed it I remember I was
like oh my God I used to always watch a
movie and then immediately watch the
director's commentary I watched the
director's commentary of the thing John
Carpenter
has an encyclopedia brain he can recall
any single like we were watching through
and he was going beat for beat all of
the production stuff all like every
every single detail he knew it's his
life though and it was 30 years ago or
whatever I guess maybe 20. I don't know
when the audio commentary was recorded
but it was insane
that I don't think that's surprising in
any case I think it's a guy who loves I
think it beats up the thing
but I think it's a complicated fight the
reason I think it succeeds is because it
is an unkillable
constant ancient entity
it is the the the
embodiment of of Destruction and panic
so the thing
yeah but the thing is just like a thing
I'm not even trying to make a joke here
um if we were having this fight and Rey
was there uh Ray would have beaten all
of them that's true that's not even me
making a joke
Palpatine Ray Skywalker he can't be
killed she can heal people yeah she has
magic powers that manifest yeah you're
not wrong
what's that do you guys know uh Joel
Haver or Haver I don't know what is
Edgerton
no he's a YouTuber he's been blowing up
you've probably seen John it's for John
it's for John what is this I want John
to uh watch him because John you're
going to be living with Alana right oh
yes if you're still there by the time I
rap because Alana got that sweet sweet
TV do you want to watch the Sergio Leo
any Trilogy because it's on Fork they've
done the 4K I've never seen any of these
westerns oh yeah if you're back because
I'm they're not out till I pre-ordered
them they're not out till May now oh
yeah I'm gonna be there in me they did a
forecast
through the end of the year
um this is known I knew that even oh
cool then we can do we can watch Obi-Wan
and we can watch
exactly around me and I have not had any
say in it oh John Let's watch
Mandalorian season three at Alana's then
in person if you're still gonna be there
I'm talking about actually watching
together when we were all oh Who Framed
Roger Rabbit we talked about that we'd
love to watch that what was that movie
we were talking about Funhouse the other
day uh that was a a lease and Ryan we're
talking about
oh [ __ ] that was like batshit insane and
I asked you about if it was like
malignant were we playing Deadly
Premonition because I was busy I was
focusing on playing today I'm so glad
that you do that I love that you pay
attention what again okay you're so
happy
um I don't know what it's called some
movie that came out that Ryan I think
hated
was it old
what movie hasn't Ryan hated every movie
I've gone to see with Ryan it may have
been I enjoy it and then he comes out
and goes I thought it was going to be
better well he loves old it doesn't
sound like Ryan at all I thought it was
gonna be better he'd be like oh there's
a movie I thought that film was gonna be
better yeah that's how he sounds you see
they're talking about him on some like
Memphis news
oh really really yeah because he came
out with a video recently where it was a
fake commercial for the Bass Pro Shop
making a water slide on their pyramid
and he put the real phone number oh my
God so people were calling Bass Pro Shop
asking when if they could get tickets to
the water slide
did that video go super viral or
something it got viral enough for it to
like cause a problem to cause a problem
in Memphis Tennessee that's amazing
gullible people wow that's awesome yeah
I I put a real phone number I looked up
where to get a phone number and where to
have a voicemail and I said I put a real
phone number in a fake commercial that I
put in one of my videos my peripherals
video
and only like 10 people called it so you
gotta get your fans guys guys something
else I want to finish the story the joke
was that it was for this fake uh fake
company
uh and it was like call now book your
appointment but then when you called the
voicemail was talking about how uh
they'd gone out of business so you set
that up or you I set that up I recorded
the voicemail message for it it was a
whole Easter egg is that hard
no it was really easy
cool I didn't know you could just like
own a number and have a it was free wow
for the voicemail for the voicemail I
guess people just like okay what were
you gonna say yeah
something that was missed because we
recorded on the cut episode yeah the
last episode was I announced
that I was doing Ghostbusters but also I
was a voice in fortnite yes and we
wanted to play yes uh and Alana and I
and Bruce and
someone else
[Laughter]
that might have been Lawrence
[Laughter]
laughs
did you actually forget yeah dude I have
that every day of my life so I forgot
John was doing it only because only
because
um
well I was gonna say we haven't we
wanted to play again so but we should do
us four
oh okay I'll do that I don't like
fortnite but I will play it with you
I've only played it once for uh it's no
Builder building and they added Rahul
can we play as you no no you can you can
buy this game what no oh yeah someone
had a skin did you see that because this
season all everything that they made was
being donated to Ukraine in one [ __ ]
week because epic gave their Fortnight
profits in the first week
they became one of the single largest
donators to Ukraine with a hundred
million that's epic's profit that's how
much they're making weekly a fortnight
I mean that's the thing about the
Activision Blizzard
um settlement is they uh
uh the for the for anyone who doesn't
know they're treating employees there's
a war in Ukraine uh it's 5.2 billion the
sexual harassment settlement for the
lawsuit was uh 18 million that's for
Activision Blizzard that's what Call of
Duty alone makes in three days yeah it's
like nothing three days of cod money
that's the thing yeah it's like all of
these laws about like uh you know
punishing giant corporations all of the
fees were made a hundred years ago or
whatever like this no it's also like
there's a lot of [ __ ] that's just like
disproportionate like the people were
getting fines for throwing parties
during covid all that does is prevent
poor people from throwing parties
because rich people are just like okay
yeah it's only it well that's how people
feel about speeding and parking tickets
it's a deterrence of the poor not the
rich whatever it's way it's so hard to
get out of poverty with you know if you
if you can't afford stuff you put it on
credit cards and then you have the
monthly payment with a high interest all
that stuff yeah I was talking yeah
basically what I'm saying is please
someone save me your health gets worse
because you don't you're you can't you
don't you know you don't want to pay yep
Yeah by letting things get worse yeah
it's the same thing with like credit
score which is like it was like well you
got a Gundam sponsorship in it oh you
got the Rooster Teeth podcast
in case you didn't know John in case you
didn't know I didn't take a cut I didn't
take a cut that is true thanks everybody
out there I don't make any money from
this show I leave it to you lot yeah
I've mentioned that before
I don't I don't take any money no you're
calling back to the to the live podcast
that no one's heard or the cut episode
as well which no one's
oh
the group chat or in person just when I
bring it up it's gonna say it yes I got
the us because I had no money my bank
account would have been like a couple
hundred dollars
um and I got sick but it was before my
insurance had gone through because I
just moved so I got sick and then I kept
working because I needed money uh and
that's how I got pneumonia for the first
time and now I am more prone to it and
my lungs are scarred because once you've
had it once you're more susceptible to
get it again poor wouldn't happen in
Australia
eaten by a wallaby or something yeah you
gotta just watch out for your wallabies
your lungs will be fine mate I got a
kidney stone two weeks before my
insurance uh at the company I was
working at went through oh oh no and I
so I went to the ER and uh it was pretty
penny did you keep it no my parent well
yeah my parents paid for the little
thing
confirm
[Laughter]
he wasn't alone I have family visiting
soon and I'm very excited about it um
but one of them is very very very unwell
and
nobody will cover the insurance for the
particular uh a health issue
so we are just kind of accepting that if
something happens when they're in the
U.S it will bankrupt them and me like
we're just like
okay uh let's do it I guess but it's
amazing I'm very aware that in a month
my entire life could be completely
destroyed
is that gonna affect me could affect you
yeah I might have to start uh paying
rent oh my God
next month
also no
it's not contagious it's a it's a it's
bone marrow disease
um I don't want to take anything like
I'm not really sure it's something it's
like a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] it's like
bone marrow or leukemia
I don't really know entirely but it's
terminal both yeah both deal breakers
for me
well the good news is I intend to kick
you out while they're here so yeah
okay you're out anyway that's true also
I know you were saying that potentially
you could have Financial issues but I
don't know if this is a good time to
mention it but next month
I might start taking a cup does it
depend on whether I'm bankrupt though I
might start taking a car depend on
whether I haven't gotten any Cuts dude
John you've made more money from this
podcast than anybody else has I haven't
I'm aware that if you've just paid for
things yeah but like a lot more for you
than anyone else I'm aware how much
balance is very in the favor I'm
actually out it is I'm out of pocket
when I went to that that stupid live
show I spent 300 at the freaking
Warhammer you know I know that I didn't
give away 300 worth of stuff 230 was
mine but that's 70 bucks out of pocket
nobody else
didn't send me the [ __ ] lift code
early enough so I had to pay for my
lifts to get to the to the auditorium
because they were supposed to Rooster
Teeth were supposed to pay for our list
so that was enough of 30 I'm 100 out see
if you hadn't watched the video game
accessibility Awards
um
he thinks when I when I when I was asked
to be firstly let's talk about the
accessibility it was when Alana first
created the accessibility Awards she
reached out to people to to give out
Awards I was asked to give out the award
uh to present the award for um
um uh color I was asked to give out the
award for what was it visual or
something yeah it was one of the the
like second Channel or something one of
the ones that pertains to to a visual
access to visual impairment and things
like that and because I'm colorblind now
you have to use colorblind settings and
then just before I was about to do it I
got kicked off doing it because they got
someone who was blind
Steve was like we could have both of
them do it and I was like I don't think
that looks great for Rahul he's with
someone who's actually blind not the
color blindness isn't blind it just
still looking [ __ ]
then you were given another one
strike one and then that's fine and then
on the second time that they do it after
you know I donate my time
uh they get Ryan Reynolds and I don't
get a phone call no more because we're
too [ __ ] big now we don't get like we
don't get you we got Ryan Reynolds so I
wasn't even asked to be a part of the
accessibility Awards the second time
strike are you serious
strike two don't tell me there's a
strike three
the third strike will result in me
well we'll see how next year's
accessibility what awards Go on stage I
might get up on stage and slap Steve
[Laughter]
you continue to push me I'm gonna snap
which question is is anyone else already
tired of and doesn't want to hear any
more oh my God teams of Will Smith it
was like dude that happened as soon as
it happened I was already exhausted
sell out for a like I got canceled so
what it became raw very cool so before
we move on I want to know because we
went to the GDC Awards
uh we were on the table that we were at
which is like very far up the front like
right next to the stage because Steve uh
won uh Steve spawns a very good friend
of mine foreigners I don't know won the
award uh the ambassador award and asked
me to present it so I wrote a speech and
we had to go up on stage and did he win
it or was he given like yeah he wasn't a
competition it was just him
um
to get the order was their single combat
involved so we were at a table that was
very far at the front and they broadcast
the thing on Twitch John have you seen
how many [ __ ] shots you're in
I think it's probably twitch.tv slash
GDC or something I don't actually know
um yeah it's really fun I honestly
didn't know that that was being recorded
or broadcast I was genuinely like yeah I
noticed that they kept experience at us
and I was like we haven't seen any shots
of the audience unlike the over no
because it was for the stream it wasn't
for us I didn't realize that like
because they kept a lot of junk someone
would walk out and be at the stand you
would see them on the overheads and so I
was like you're in footage of why do
they keep doing the reactions seeing
myself on the owner heads yeah you're in
it all the time it's really funny
um and I love that also yeah I did not
know John I will need to check that out
people kept talking about how hard game
development is and like all the things
that are difficult and John across the
table just kept going
totally yeah which driving me [ __ ]
nuts I know
I'm more of a game developer than you
you just write for him that's true yeah
you don't you don't Dev any of it I but
I do
we're all deaf so much of my job is
narrative design I voice so I'm a Dev
owners in development
um what do you how do you feel about
being a fellow Dev John
I love it yeah
um uh do you know what I hate it was um
was it called crunch oh yeah oh that's
my tits in
it does my tits in as well bloody crunch
nipple to the curb I don't want crunch
um I have not experienced any Crunch at
Sony Santa Monica Studio
which shout out to Sony Santa Monica
Studio
are you reading something right now
Corey's under the table
t
that's good that's very which is like
extremely common it's because they
barely they they're like it's she's a
glamor uh higher yeah
yep she doesn't actually do anything
thank you appreciate that yep
um wow
I don't know about you but if I was
right in a video game I would love to uh
be sitting across from Alana uh brighten
up the place she looks great sugar tits
did I tell you about there was one time
that a very popular well-known headset
company reached out to me was like we
want to send you one of our headsets
um would you like the pink one because
you're so cute
whoa and I was like no I'm good but
thank you
[ __ ] no are you gonna do you wear the
glasses uh when you're writing no I'm
actually
um I'm nearsighted so it's things that
are far away that's the problem you know
when wearing too insane oh the MILF
classes the MILF glasses it's again all
glasses on me just look milfy it's
unfortunate
if you you need to wait on the podcast
because otherwise I'm gonna make a
finner act up well Alana it's because
you don't wear them you just hold them
like this yeah it's because I
yeah I don't know but I don't know why
that's happened just put them on the
others if I've never had to wear glasses
ever but I imagine it'd be the same oh
they would definitely
I've been starting wearing contacts
because I don't wear glasses but
recently for work I I've been about to
try on contact lenses
um like to change your eye color yeah
and stuff like that and like it they
have a they have the person come on set
and like do it for it's it I don't know
man
my whole life without someone and now I
and I don't just have like they're not
like the ones just for the the yeah the
iris they cover the uh what's the white
bit called
thank you John so yeah like the rest of
my clitor uh it's it's like
it it feels like I've got instead of an
eyelash like a horse hair around here
yeah yeah I could not imagine and they
instantly put it in right so they put it
in my eye and I'm like they pull they go
keep looking keep looking down keep
looking down and do it and they force it
in and they shut they start rubbing and
within seconds they're like is it good
does it feel good and I'm like I don't
know about rubbing and then they ask you
if it feels good it's it's too it's too
it's too soon ask me 10 minutes if it's
still I only ever want contact lenses
for cosplay and uh I am so bad at
putting them in that I would do my
makeup try to put the contacts in and
then end up crying and having to start
the whole process ever again and it
takes me so long and I'm getting these
contacts and dropping them in the sink
so they're having to clean them again
and they're just [ __ ] everywhere and
getting dust I'm so bad at putting them
in I don't know how don't and have you
worn them because you like actually need
glasses all the time no I've never worn
them I never plan to I same thing where
there are these eye color changing ones
that we bought for some short film or
something and I was like I'm gonna try
it like the day before whatever and I
went to the bathroom
I gave up because my eye my brain would
not let me put a thing on my eyes nope
it's awful
yeah I don't know how there are some
people I didn't cry though like a little
[ __ ] I wish I could show you a picture
of it I won't be able to show you a
picture for ages but it's a it's a
gnarly call contact
UM it looks so legit when it's in are
they like Anakin yellow eyes what he's
doing the the turn maybe
I have a pair of contacts that's the
Juggalo logo oh the guy with the ax how
am I cool I have one that's a
Confederate flag
put it in your eyes not [ __ ] welcome
by the way do you guys know that it's
like a iron cross or something is that
what it is Iron Cross yeah we were going
to talk about Jada and will because
that's a Nazi thing right I think it
sounds yeah I think so yeah it was like
a metal or something and a symbol
yesterday yeah it is Nazi yep you my dad
and I were driving he was on this huge
hog like a like a Harley or whatever oh
but it was it was lime green
and it and it had iron the the rear view
mirrors on on each side were an iron
cross his helmet had an iron cross the
like license photo ever had an eye in
Christ it was all Iron Cross themed out
except it was a lime green which isn't
like army green
or
a German soldier
because apparently darker than this but
it was like this kind of green the the
Iron Cross is awarded for outstanding
bravery or service during war time for
Germans so I guess it was used in Nazi
Germany but
came from the German Empire it isn't it
wasn't created by yeah but any American
it's like it's like the purple heart for
the bad guys
yeah
they've just reintroduced it and there's
a different version of it or because
wouldn't the Vietnamese look at the
Purple Heart as the Iron Cross and be
like that's true it's all perspective I
guess that's true
um so I got canceled it's all
perspective oh go on speaking of
perspective
I uh don't I've spent most of 2022 not
having any type of hot takes anymore I
don't care I hate Twitter I hate people
I think you're all garbage and I don't
ultimately don't care what you think wow
it's a it's whether it's about I don't
learn anything from it if you shout at
me I delete it and still feel the same
way except I probably double it down
double down and never vocalize it you
don't learn you're just bullied into
shutting up it doesn't do anything right
sometimes you might have an informed
conversation anyway
when I saw the thing on the Oscars I was
like whoa there's got to be a better way
to handle that no matter how you felt
about what was said
that's [ __ ] up that's assault and
within within about 60 seconds
or maybe even more the the quote tweet
number Rose so fast
and I was like I don't think these
people are agreeing with me I looked at
the quote tweets and it was like [ __ ]
off you brown piece of [ __ ] Desi men
embarrassing us again keep your [ __ ]
nose out of our business and all of this
stuff and I'm saying whoa oh my God I
made a hot take that was spicy you
didn't know it was like I was out there
I was like what have I missed and
because ultimately like most of us
we don't care pasts going that was wild
in it yeah yeah
and you move on because I had such I
care so little about Jada will and Chris
Rock and the Oscars other if if we were
all just going to tell a joke about it
for a while it's fine but if we're gonna
Deep dive into what this means and how
is this linked to white supremacy and
what this is and what that is I don't
know if any if it's like that's the bit
where it becomes exhausting the think
pieces and what this greater means and
because I was getting so hardly ratioed
hard
so hard
um I just I love uh wild wild west
but like I was like oh this is a hill I
don't need to die on like yeah I don't I
don't need this in my life I don't
actually care about the lives of
millionaires uh you know a millionaire
slapped another millionaire defending a
millionaire at a what an award show of
the one percent celebrating the one
percent and I was like I think I'm gonna
peace out on this one
but there's the button it caught anyone
who said anything like they found some
[ __ ] from Zoe Kravitz because she said
something and they were like yo didn't
you say that you thought Jaden was
attractive when he was 14 like
I woke up one morning and Clint Eastwood
was a hashtag and I was like it's my
[ __ ] dead
is my boy dead he's like no he talked to
an empty chair at the NRA even better in
1963
when Little Feather came up on stage and
accepted the Academy Award for best
actor for Marlon on behalf of Marlon
Brando to then talk about how Native
Americans had been treated in Hollywood
in particular during that time John
Wayne was apparently vocally displeased
with the with the now
I don't know if he's vocally displeased
with the message Brando the stunt her
what it means but he was what we do know
is is that he was annoyed and stood up
and was asked to sit back down or
whatever
and then Clint Eastwood was next up to
then present best picture and he came
out to an audience that were like well
that was weird that was a strange thing
we just had happen when Brandon didn't
show up and Clint goes
I don't know if I should accept this
award on behalf of all the Cowboys
killed in in John Ford movies and then
everyone let the tension out and laughed
in 1963 little did that [ __ ] know that
in like
60 years later or something they're like
[ __ ] out of line how dare you make a
joke like that insensitive so at 92 I
mean Clint Eastwood is problematic but I
do also think absolutely one of the
things he talks about the internet is uh
removing the context of time we're all
just fine with not caring how long ago
something was oh yeah like you watch any
movie from before like 2009
casually yeah
the sexism is also very potent recently
yeah do you remember to remember when
Toby Maguire in in Spider-Man's like to
Randy Macho Man Randy Savage like hey
nice outfit would your boyfriend make it
for you and they're like yeah what if he
did you [ __ ] I'm a fire
that's only Spiderman yeah that was
that's that's the 21st century
um but but no I mean I I could Clint's a
funny one because I fully separate the
art and the artist he's he's my like my
exception and I think that's the [ __ ]
up thing we can't we all do it and the
and I hate that we somehow it's you're
judged for like we all have our
exceptions I'm willing
I'm willing to enjoy Clint's work as an
actor and a director and his influence
on me as an actor and my father and I'll
ignore that Clint probably wants me to
[ __ ] off back to where I came from I
mean he's 92 years old he was around
during World War II you know what I mean
like he's an old he's a grandpa with a
platform one of the most dangerous
things you could have right now to be
old out of touch and also have a
platform but Rahul what would you say if
Clint Eastwood asked you how Vancouver
is
what do you mean trying to bring it back
to travel
wait I'm coming I'll bring it I'll bring
about watch this I'll bring it back I'll
bring it back yeah
um JK Rowling for instance okay all
right [ __ ] me I I am I don't
care I won't watch Harry Potter
oh congrats
I won't I I like for me I won't I since
I don't we're JK Rowling I like the way
she's been has affected how I feel about
Harry Potter so it's easy for me to go
no like it's personal everybody pick and
choose you pick and choose
um I agree that's why basically every
pedo I still love watching their movies
almost even more
foreign
I remember talking to you about it in
Vegas we were walking past like a whole
bunch of just Michael Jackson images on
the wall yeah it makes me uncomfortable
yeah because like God is music's so
[ __ ] good yeah it's incredible his
music's incredible
sorry Rahul do you want to finish up
with your boring whatever you're saying
if
um
Vancouver is rainy
something about JK Rowling oh yeah you
pick and choose that's it it's like
you're picking shoes yeah
um
in sorry let's talk about the trouble
that none of us really do sorry let's go
let's go to Boston to Philadelphia
um in Philadelphia I think is where I
mean that's where High Fidelity the
movie takes place which is a book that I
read and as a young boy a young uh
whippersnapper 19 year old a very moved
but you're not a boy
anyways uh they remade it
um
starring Zoe Kravitz
and in it there's a monologue about how
um Michael Jackson
uh
like the I I don't remember what albums
they are but like Stevie Wonder produced
most of his music and like
is it Stevie Wonder I might be confusing
him with someone else or no it's not
Stevie Wonder it's the guy from uh
Arrested Development that Mo Phillips is
obsessed with anyways oh um um James
Quincy Jones Quincy Jones yeah Quincy
Jones Quincy Jones produced all those
albums and a lot of like at least for
musicians
uh well it's also the same for movies
because the for an actor they're just
one person in a production of hundreds
and hundreds of people and music is the
same way a lot of times the lead person
like Michael Jackson he was just the
voice and had some inspiration uh as
part of it but like that the sound and
like how it came out is a lot of it was
Quincy Jones and probably something
musicians and stuff and so they talked
about how I was like
you know just because Michael Jackson
turned out to be a monster doesn't mean
we should be denied the beauty of Quincy
Jones's like musical prowess
um
so that's why I love watching seven
that's why I love watching you are the
biggest you are the biggest Roman
Polanski fan I know it's true I've never
seen one of his films but I am a big fan
what was what was his I was The Pianist
right was the one where he was on the
run and then everything yeah he was like
fighting out in Paris [ __ ] me
yeah I mean it's messy like I said like
I think I think I think if you can
separate art from artists cool if you
can't cool and if you do everyone does
it with who whoever they are invested
with more yeah but seriously for me it's
so rx78 yeah fondled uh titty in 1992
Jacob's gonna stand by
my man yeah I'm so it's fine I'm just
letting it happen uh All I'm gonna say
is uh what do you mean like I've known
so many people in my real life that I've
loved and like held respect for that
have turned out to be either just shitty
people or like actual monsters that
I just assume that everyone is secretly
like a terrible person that's the way to
live
yes well I I'm just so like when I'm
watching stuff it's like I have to
separate it like I have to
because I don't want to be let down
again but you shouldn't not separate it
anyway because you're not watching that
person you are watching a character Like
It by definition I separate Alana from
play watch listen
the only way to consume it yeah I have
to put aside how problem and I go I want
to watch these four talk about games
otherwise
I was just sitting here silently and I'm
now I'm just being attacked again you
want us to change topics so we're
changing topic yeah and the top the
topic is just straight for like this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what else are we supposed
to talk about
we talk about
it's the thing who wins
Ray apparently yeah
she is like it's like scissor paper
Stone what's the one what the [ __ ] this
is a paper sorry we call it scissors
paper scissors What
scissor paper Stones you call it uses
I feel like Jacob and anken
um
Ancient Ancient I can't even wait that
doesn't you call it rock paper scissors
yeah
we go scissor paper Stone this is a
paper Stone says the paper Stone this is
a paper Stone what the [ __ ]
your weight okay
do you go uh uh one uh one two three
four I declare a thumb thumb war touch
Bell begin no no five six seven eight
tracks yeah it's five six seven eight
try to keep your thumbs yeah then just
goes right into it well either thumb war
TouchPal begin maybe that's what Asians
us Asians do we bow I will say though
Rahul that was it slicers
uh writer's rock or no it was scissor
paper Stone slices Rock
this is rock paper scissors scissor
paper this is your favorite stuff is
right
[Laughter]
come on what
[Laughter]
knife you got just dismiss that as a
thing you just said geez listen they
talk weird this is like a free Elden
ring classes
um were they ending on Stone I like yeah
scissor paper stopwise because it feels
like seriously
in Australia it finishes his paper rock
what yeah so you're doing the same thing
as us says we say stone and you say well
so I like you keep saying scissor like
it's a single like like singular scissor
scissor scissor paper yeah they they
just use knives yeah they're pretty
stabby over there because they don't
have guns
we're gonna criticize
um apparently this is what all Brits do
on Twitter apparently yeah but we don't
have school shootings it's fair really
it's fair I mean I get that I do that
whenever people talk about how dangerous
the animals in Australia are
you're afraid of the animals we're
afraid of the people
Americans get really upset if you
because apparently so it's anyone who's
not in America if we're ever criticized
like if the Brits are made fun of for
their accent or stabbings or it's
Tuesday me apparently nine times out of
ten any European Aussie your key we will
be like uh you have to pay for your
medical uh yeah they've got health care
and you [ __ ] have school shootings in
mass shootings and then they're like
oh we're just making fun of your accent
why'd you have to leave it internally in
America it's kind of like really upset
about criticizing America as a as an
institution well that is true they they
really breathe that in here with the
whole oh yeah
allegiance to the flag the funny thing
is is that if Americans if Americans saw
footage of school kids standing up every
morning in front of a flag with their
hand over their chest they can't [ __ ]
commies do people still do that yeah I
have no idea I didn't do it at my high
school I still do it yeah if she
indoctrinates all those children Tara
would have to lead
if she does she she plays it on the drum
oh cool yeah
classic Terror to the United States
here's the funny thing on the reverse
side my dad actually this morning was
like we were talking about health care
and he's like healthcare is so good here
I wonder would be like in another
country to have to like go through this
and I was like sorry Dad I have bad news
yeah tell your dad to just drive just
drive up here 20 hours yeah it changes
the other car a lot of these Americans
that are into Canada with like a giant
tumor well they just remove it no
um I'm not sure because like I think in
the UK if you were in a car accident NHS
are going to take care of you the
ambulance is going to come and that's
true same in Australia chew up and
you're gonna be fine so I assume
Vancouver's will be if I got hit by a
car here I'm assuming Canada are going
to take care of me yeah it'd only cost
you a [ __ ] ton in the US yeah I don't
know because I once took a friend here
to the hospital
um when they overdosed on drugs
why is that
[Laughter]
why is what happened
what that was unpropped
what
what are you laughing at I'm just
laughing because it's true and who it is
anyway
um and I forgot I just haven't thought
about in a while oh my God
anyway oh that's hilarious yeah that is
super funny actually
they got billed and it was in Vancouver
because I remember them trying to run
away
after they were patched up
but like I remember them being billed
like a thousand and that was Canada
because it was Vancouver so I don't know
that's nothing I know but like we
wouldn't have balance is like 8K
so when I had an ambulance and I came
off the bike and I couldn't walk for
[ __ ] ages and my hands were on fire
and bleeding and my knee was broken and
super [ __ ] up uh it was awful my knee
was horrendous
um they were like yeah we're not gonna
take you to the hospital because it'll
cost you a bunch of money uh you'll be
fine
um can you ride home I was like can I
ride home
no oh my God
what
about riding home like you can use they
did say that they genuinely were like
would you be able to ride home and I was
like are you [ __ ] serious I couldn't
walk for ages of course I could [ __ ]
ride home but they were like it's not
worth the money
um and if we don't make a record of this
the [ __ ] up because because the break
is effectively the attitude is like
you're gonna do the same thing that they
would have you do at the hospital which
is clean your way your knees broken
is that you you weren't riding a bicycle
you were going 32 miles an hour right it
is a motorbike at 32 sure at 12 11
whatever and mind you hit the road at 32
miles an hour
yeah so you were in theory riding a
motorbike at 30 miles an hour on a on a
on a street and they were like
like
maybe just go home
but they told me it would be so
expensive yeah they told me they said it
would be so expensive that it wasn't
worth it for the cost and that they
weren't even going to write me up for
the ambulance um but they also said the
hospital was so overrun with covid that
if I were to go because it was at the
start of
2020 2021 they were like they probably
won't see you for hours your risk of
catching covert is high like it's just
not worth even going so they literally
just were like [ __ ] go home uh didn't
Clean My Wounds none of it it was nuts I
did ask the first question that I asked
the uh ambulance was if my shoes were
okay because I was wearing
um some new Jordans and he was like your
shoes are sick and they're good and I
was like thank you but yeah they
literally just told me to go home so I
did and it was fine but I because I took
so long for me to actually properly get
my knee assessed
it I made the problem so much worse over
a long period of time and ended up this
is such a like a good round out to this
conversation going to a doctor in
Australia for help because it was free
so when I went home I went to the doctor
and they were like okay your knees in
really bad shape because basically why
didn't you come back why didn't you get
this look every time well I did have
like some virtual calls but every time
that I was I was trying to get back to
exercising because I got so frustrated
about how much weight I had gained I was
making it worse and it was getting
swollen and then I couldn't walk for
several days again so I just kept
[ __ ] it up over and over and over
again and so they were like here's what
you need to do they they basically gave
me a bunch of strength exercises told me
no cardio do a bunch of [ __ ] to like try
to get your muscles back so that you're
supporting the knee and not just putting
all your weight on the knee but yeah I
literally waited until I went to
Australia for them to be like this is
[ __ ] up you need to do something yeah
you then after this accident this is why
you then created the accessibility
Awards yeah because I broke my knees
yeah have you been on a bike since no I
went on my dad's motorbike in Australia
and my dad's been riding motorbikes my
whole life he's very safe but I was real
scared it was it was hot and I told him
I would be and he was like I know we'll
make sure that you feel okay but your
dad said it's okay it'll be fine he was
trying to say don't be a little [ __ ]
stupid corn oh my dad's real cute no he
he was really excited about uh going on
the bike because it meant that he got to
plait my hair he was like could I could
I do your hair up so that because he
used to do it when I was a little girl
he used to like helped my sister and I
brush her hair so he was like oh I want
to plot it I was like I can do it he was
like no no I won't do it so I let him
flap my hair and he like did a little
knot and he was like is it tight enough
it's not going to hit you I was like
it's good dad thank you
it was for his birthday actually it was
super fun yeah my dad's a little cutie
he's got what box he got I never
remember he calls it solo Freedom which
is very lame but I'm sick he is he wait
is it lime green and it has iron crosses
your dad was in the states very recent
Alana I have a confession to make it's
something I've been holding in for a
long time and I don't think I should say
it but I'm already saying okay
you going through that experience of
crashing the bike I'm it must have been
so hard right
and I understand all the pain you went
through and everything
but from it from uh outsider's
perspective say from someone who doesn't
know you
the fact that you posted a picture I'm
going out on this bike and then an hour
later posted a picture of your hands all
banded up saying I crashed my bike
I couldn't help but laugh
I'm so sorry I didn't post anything
until several days later
so they were separate
but I don't have a problem with that
because like I didn't even like I didn't
feel traumatized by the experience it
sucked
um and was very
painful and [ __ ] me up for months oh
yeah I know I understand it's fine with
me you're welcome too no it was just I
just thought it was it was I did have to
be like careful about what I was saying
though because if I had got charged it
wasn't my fault
um so did you crash into a car I'm still
not giving details about it so uh really
I was a DJ no in case I do end up doing
I'm getting a feat no no no I didn't
hurt anyone I was hurt but it was
someone else's fault so someone else
don't give details someone else would be
liable for my injuries if I were to get
charged for them because it's a
five-year window I did not hurt anyone
what did you technically somebody is
responsible for me being hurt that's
fair yeah I was hurt by someone it was
Rahul Rahul ran you over with his car I
never laughed at yourself sure
I'm actually speaking for Jacob at that
time Jacob was the one who left Jacob
I'm sorry it couldn't help
I find all
non-lethal or like long-term damage
injuries [ __ ] hilarious
I'm not a fan of like I don't find
videos where people get hurt funny
um I don't like I just go because I like
just care about people but there's
definitely some weird [ __ ] that I find
hilarious like the ending of the movie
Mist anything that is like comically
unfortunate I think is [ __ ] hilarious
bro I thought that was one of the
funniest [ __ ] I agree but so like
I've said that before
that movie wasn't very good
ending
when you show me these movies I'm
initially annoyed
because I'm like why is that why is that
yeah why is that performance so bad why
has that slipped through what how is
that the best take that they've done and
as time goes on that movie's good I'm
like I'm like no I had mad issues with
that so what do you [ __ ] know I did
like her husband
I did like hereditary I just didn't like
the ending doesn't like anything
no because I talk more [ __ ] about my own
projects than I do about other people
but but but no I liked I thought
malignant I'm so glad we watched I
couldn't stop laughing right he's a
cover version the chair throw yeah all
of it I was actually
and because of it like
um recently this week funny enough I was
with me and Mike were talking about
malignant
uh in the tent and like uh trying to
understand like
what this this was this aiming for the
break what the [ __ ] is going on like oh
if it's if it's intentional it's one of
the best movies ever made I think it's
like if you were if you were setting out
to be like I'm gonna take you on a wild
I think I think that's intentional for
sure I think that's definitely nuts he's
an established yeah
for sure so he's so if that's if if I
said to you guys I want to make a like
there's a movie I really want to watch
and I'm [ __ ] I might even watch it
tonight
um I really want to watch Black Dynamite
oh yeah and it was as soon as I'd seen
the trailers for Black Dynamite I was so
[ __ ] on board for like a uh an homage
to black exploitation movies and like
they leave the the boom mic you can see
and they'll sometimes read their own
stage Direction and I was like I am so
down for this movie and I just never got
around to it if malignant yes if
malignant was going for that
in the sense of like
I'm gonna actually tell good actors to
play it badly then I think it might be
the perfect movie
I think they might have just hired found
no because what the lead is from peaky
blinders and she's brilliant in it uh oh
what about the sister the best actor in
the movie
The sister is in the Fall of the House
of Usher and she's a good friend of mine
and she's wonderful
oh her line delivery right I think we
can see I just made I just made that up
to see if you look with me
squirmative
oh that was something we talked about on
the cancer
so yeah
in fortnite I have a themed tune
and
it's uh it's a wrap
um Alana loves it it's now her ringtone
I see if this will work this time
nope
so I have a rap song
arguably
one of the worst songs I've ever heard
in my entire life so bad
um can we can you just play it are you
no are we allowed no it doesn't matter
because of patreon this podcast can get
demonetized it's it makes The Chemical
Brothers one that I heard when I was
high
sound like Mozart
is that like the FIFA one or something
yeah yeah yeah and the Darkness
that was the weed gummy but um but yeah
so so I was hyped and then you know my
audio files leaked the night before the
announcement and then there was like an
origin theme tune you can buy and it's
this song
it is a legit like
ear cancer it's like one of the worst
things I've ever heard
um shout out to Epic though I do love
being in the game and thank you so much
for having me it's been an honor but the
song [ __ ] sucks so hard it sucked so
hard actually [ __ ] it it sucks so hard I
love it it's malignant
here here's the top comment on uh on the
video well it's the track or whatever
it's not a video oh on YouTube yeah it
hasn't even been a day and the origin is
already my new favorite member of the
seventh oh his armor his backstory and
this song are awesome I hope we get a
skin of his Cube King Persona hey
I'm the cube King apparently oh cool
well what are you asking me
it's in the law like
um it's part of this law what about it
like can you elaborate on the law I'm
sure fortnite fans would really love to
hear from you what would they like to
know um well about the law tell us about
the literally anything just literally
one little you know um you know tilted
Towers yeah you can't of course cool
so you know
um anyway so when I was in the group
chat
[Laughter]
that's all I know tilted Towers when I
was in the group chat because I know
Jacob's a [ __ ] pussy-o
um in the group chat I sent the uh the
song knowing that Alana thought it was
one of the worst things she's ever heard
and I agreed
and I I excitedly sent the link and said
to John and Jacob oh my God how cool is
this I've also got my own theme tune
this is [ __ ] awesome how good is this
track and Jacob was like replies with
yeah it's really cool or something what
did you say awesome oh my God it's so
good yeah it's so good or something and
then I was like Jacob you're full of
[ __ ] it's one of the worst [ __ ]
things I've ever thought and while I
take a full of [ __ ] yeah yeah well I
almost feel like Foo Fighters and
Breaking Benjamin I don't have any
favorite reference
Jacob rest in peace
yeah I was so sad about that I've been
meaning to watch like the Foo Fighters
like a horror movie that movie yeah what
studio 666. yeah you did it yeah should
we save it for should we save it for a
uh
movie night yeah yeah I love I love
idiots in a broad movie night yeah what
if we what have we got under our English
oh a master's Universe
um oh I must see Universe we watch you
play Fort or uh Forza
yeah
it wasn't weird it was pretty weird it
wasn't okay
I have a very specific reason why it
wasn't weird but I'm gonna call you out
on a podcast okay that's fair
um
and malignant I think that's that's it
we haven't watched anything else we
watched Elden ring which yeah I watched
I didn't we watched you yeah right
godric single combat oh nephily was
there but I wasn't there for that no
John wasn't there for that that was uh
Charlotte
and then Charlotte tweeted the next day
that she did it she finished it and took
the what what we figured out same strats
jelly uh mushroom mushroom that's right
but you're calling the jellyfish a
mushroom I kept forgetting that it's a
jellyfish and I kept thinking it was a
floating mushroom
so whenever I'd summer it'd be like
mushrooms
clearly a jellyfish yeah
um same phallic all right should we end
it there my friends got a mushroom tip
yeah thank you for watching this episode
of idiots and a broad thank you to
gundam Evolution for sponsoring us we
are going to be playing the game when it
comes out I'm very excited about it oh
yeah uh we will see you next episode
which will be first Monday of every
month
May 2nd my friends
just before Obi-Wan oh yep I hope it
doesn't suck
really worried that it will
probably will it'll have some week Week
episodes oh yeah anyways oh oh stop
recording too
[Music]
foreign